m
[Musique]
c'est nous
m
[Musique]
wyatt les trois finitions
jimmy choo en tee shirt n'est pas
dépassé on est passé quelques jours
avant tout à des prix justes mais les
ablettes la doc soit un iphone
[Rires]
[Musique]
les mecs comme facebook mark zuckerberg
très violente
pourquoi tu es bien méchant mais
puisqu'une avant apple c'est pas mal non
plus steve jobs compte a dit steve jobs
justice
je sens pour brésil en vue à vous ma vie
[Rires]
classe mais genre tu ne crois pas que
des bonnes ambiances
il me dit ville livré là dit elle
revivait au nom de bell
[Rires]
tranquille
[Musique]
j'aimerais qu'on fasse
[Applaudissements]
il faut qu'on se libère les siens
je pense aussi au premier mais vous les
promesses du genre
et ans elle appelle la ténacité père
aulas les enfants et sur la même couleur
[Musique]
on est là
en
à quel moment
si jeanne ferron vérité est ce que dit
on risquerait d'être parent se souvenait
de moi
sur twitter à chaud et pour monsieur
le palais
[Applaudissements]
alors
john holmes